Thank you.
Hey, how are you doing, man?
I'm going to give you a speaker invite, but you don't have to speak when people are here
or whatever, just because, you know, no one is here.
If you want to chat or whatever, I wonder how France is doing, like how you guys are processing
all this over there.
There's, you know, I mean, we only get, you know, we only get like certain news and it's
usually only about like the people who are really in charge or who seem in charge, right?
Like we don't get information about like what the average French person thinks or what, you
know, the general consensus is.
We hear like, this is what Macron said, that type of thing.
It seems like.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
No.
Thank you, GT.
I'm happy to see, to hear from you again.
I remember the space you made where we're quite good.
So I'm always willing to, to listen if you made something, that's why I'm here.
But thanks.
Hey, thanks.
You know, we, um, we made some spaces last year, uh, talking about like all of this stuff
that was going to happen.
Right.
Um, there's, you know, we, we have, um, we had, right.
We, I had a remote viewers working with me at that point in time, or at least as far
as the spaces were concerned.
So we had the remote viewing, uh, we had, um, the astrology.
I, um, I spent a lot of time studying these.
Hey, Melissa, I spent a lot of time studying these topics.
Like I spent a couple of years studying comparative eschatology.
Um, I spent a couple of years studying, you know, fossil fuels and physical economy and, you
know, the stuff that's going on right now after nine 11, I was very concerned about it.
Um, straights of homoos, that type of thing.
So we touched on all this stuff last year because this was, this was clearly indicated,
um, at this point in time by a specific astrological transit, which was, uh, Neptune, sorry, Saturn
conjunct Neptune, which was exact on the 20th of February.
Um, these, these are, these, um, Saturn transits conjunct the outer planets happen every 30 to
four years and they always precede some sort of crisis, uh, Pluto conjunct, or sorry, Saturn
conjunct Pluto usually precedes a pandemic.
And so, um, Saturn conjunct Pluto happened immediately prior to the onset of AIDS.
And it happened again, immediately prior to the pandemic, right?
So, um, Saturn and Pluto were conjunct exactly on January 11th, 2020 and astrologers had made
predictions going back probably 20 or 30 years prior to that, um, about a pandemic at that time.
Not every astrologer, some astrologers, um, but most astrologers don't think about things like
that.
So when that started to happen, um, when the pandemic started to, um, become a thing, like we, we got the
news on the 12th of January here in the United States.
I don't know how it was in France.
Um, but no one paid any attention to it at all.
So the pandemic protocols that were in operation in 2020 weren't written by the UN.
They weren't designed by the UN.
Um, they were adopted by the UN.
They were designed by the U S following nine 11 under the Bush administration.
People have very short memories.
So they had forgotten all of that, which, you know, a lot of it wasn't discussed, but it was
frequently in the news.
Some of it was frequently in the news, uh, back at that time, because one of the concerns was
biological warfare.
So, um, like everything that happened in the pandemic, they tried to do here and to, or they,
well, I'm going to say try to do that.
There were suggestions that that stuff might happen here in 2009 as the result of a, uh,
swine flu or bird flu, swine flu.
I think that year, a flu, um, crisis or a predicted flu crisis, the Obama administration was preparing
to implement the very same procedures that, um, the world ended up implementing during the pandemic.
So they had been written a long time ago.
And if you were familiar with them,
and you also had like some knowledge of prediction, then, you know, it was, it was as I, as I was,
right, it was pretty obvious to me what was going to happen.
So in January of 2020, I, I tried to calmly, slowly introduce the idea of what was going to
happen to my family and friends.
Um, I wasn't capable of, um, anything public at that time.
I'd just been in a major accident in 2019.
It took me three years to get back to like functional, basically functional.
I'm disabled now, but like, um, like I was still, when the pandemic began, I was still having
frequent surgeries, I still had, um, I still had a, um, a concussion, uh, a serious traumatic brain injury,
um, blood clots, like all kinds of things.
I was almost, I almost died, I almost died like five times.
Right.
So I wasn't capable at that time of really, um, having social media discussions with people,
talking online, writing anything, all of that was off the table.
So I was more of like, um, I was forced into the role of an observer during that period,
but I could tell my family and friends what was going to happen.
And even though it was very clear on the 12th of January, 2020, what was going to happen
because there was like, you have to, you have to have experience.
You have to have, you know, you understand this, like with your previous lines of work,
right?
You have to have a certain level of experience before things seem real to you.
Um, so there were still people that I knew who were very deeply in denial in April, uh,
after we'd already begun three weeks to stop the spread.
Um, and then, uh, we, we try to avoid this topic on social media simply because like algorithms
are funny about it.
Right.
Um, but I, I don't avoid it out of cowardice.
It's just that we want people to be able to hear what we have to say about other topics.
Uh, so when the, um, when the vaccinations, um, we're probably going to lose the algorithm
is probably going to, algorithm is probably not going to show anyone the post now, but
anyhow, uh, when that occurred, right?
Like I understood what was going on then as well, but again, I wasn't really capable of
doing anything.
I was in a wheelchair and I was just staring at the screen of the TV every day going, I
can't believe this is happening.
Um, because that specific information like, uh, had been much discussed in like alternative
circles in the late nineties and early 2000.
So like we understood that stuff was coming at that time, there were videos made about it.
Like they're still available online, but if I start rattling off the names of these videos,
they're available on YouTube and stuff.
Uh, you know, absolutely no one is going to see the, um, the, um, that we have this space
right now.
Okay.
So, but, but there were like everything that was happening, including the, um, I'm going
to, okay, cool.
Um, pretty much any, everything involving like, um, the questions everyone has now or had at
that time about the injections and what, what was going on with them.
Like that was all stuff that if you had been active, like listening to coast to coast AM and
late nineties, and if you had a good memory, you would remember all the details about from
that time and there were like 7 million listeners, um, in the nineties overnight on coast to coast
AM, but people have, again, poor memories, but I would, I would bet though, if we went back
and we looked at like the people who had an issue, who raised, um, concerns and we asked
them how many of you have, or were, you know, coast to coast AM listeners in the 1990s, I bet
you the majority were, uh, that that's just my assumption.
Um, so with this, right, like we're, we're in this situation right now, the conjunction
of, I'm sorry, I just have to, I saw a message from someone, but I can't see the message from
them.
I'm not really sure, um, what they were saying and I don't want to be rude.
Uh, I guess, I guess I'm just going to have to be rude and not know what people, okay.
So, um, yeah, this from, from an astrological standpoint, um, the conjunction of Saturn and
Neptune on February 20th, it's been, um, it's been active since, uh, July of, uh, of last
year.
So that, um, that conjunction occurred at zero degrees Aries and zero degrees Aries is the
ascendant point for reality or the world or the earth or however you want to look at it.
So any conjunction that happens there is more important, just like it would be if it happened
to anyone here on their ascendant, right?
If you have a, a transit to your ascendant, it's probably going to be amongst the most important
transits that occur in your life.
When there is a major outer planet conjunction at zero degrees Aries, that conjunction basically
steers history from that point forward until there is another different outer planet conjunction
at zero degrees Aries.
That might be something that happens in 10 years, or it might be something that happens in a thousand
years.
It really depends.
Uh, the last one was, uh, 2010, but that's highly unusual for there to be an outer planet
conjunction at zero degrees Aries.
So I don't know.
We know it's going to be hundreds of years.
We don't know how many hundreds of years.
Um, we definitely know that as far as astrological mundane transits, conjunctions, events are concerned.
And this is the, the most active, uh, period in our lifetimes, right?
Like the events right now are going to overshadow the events of 2020 significantly.
And this is something I made spaces about last year.
The reason I actually came back on X in 2023 was to start talking about this.
Um, so I posted about hundreds of times and run a bunch of spaces, but look at people.
Look to social media, at least X is, is a form of entertainment, right?
And it's sort of unfortunate because it'd be nice to have it be a venue for sharing knowledge.
Traditionally, this, this type of form, right?
Is very, um, Athenian, right?
And, you know, very like, uh, Plato and Socrates, you know, it works very well for, for, um, exchanging
knowledge and, and, uh, learning things, but that's not what people do.
People are really interested in here and that's all right.
Uh, it is what it is.
So I had, uh, mostly determined to, to not run very many more spaces.
Um, because like last time I had this, and I'm not going to digress too much, but just
to explain it.
Last time I had this, I ran this space.
Um, I, I sort of tuned into the, tuned in late to the work of, um, Dean Radden around
the psychic gene.
And when I looked into it, cause I'd never looked into it before, um, it just wasn't
pressing for me.
Um, I found this glaring discrepancy and I found that what he had actually stumbled upon
was much bigger than what he was talking about, what, what, what he saw in the information.
And so I was super stoked.
I didn't think a lot of people would show up and I'm like, you know, we could just get,
you know, 20 or 30 people.
This would be great to share this information because what I identified, as far as I can
tell, no one else has.
It doesn't mean no one will, but it was, it's big.
Right.
And it will be big.
And I'm like, this is like a world exclusive.
This is amazing.
How could I, you know, once in a lifetime and no one gave a fuck.
So look, that's cool.
Right.
It's not probably not entertaining topic and that's all right.
But then, you know, then I realized, fuck it.
Um, I'm going to limit the number of spaces I do going forward.
However, now this is unfolding and it's unfolding the way we predict it.
Right.
Like you guys are all great.
Like I, you know, I'm not, there are casts, not cast.
There are crass.
I haven't done a space in a while.
So I'm going to be like just worse than usual.
Look, so there are like crass individuals.
Right.
And it's pretty much the norm now.
Don't give a shit about anyone.
Um, it's not a strength to, to really be concerned about people who aren't concerned about you.
Not, you know, not that's a, but this, this isn't a complaint.
I'm saying it's not like, um, it's a reason why.
Right.
The trade is sort of, it disappears in an advanced society like ours.
So I'm not, this isn't a humble brag, but, but I do, I do feel concerned for people that I've talked to.
Hey, how you doing, man?
Um, you know, online or who've supported me in any way.
And I'm like, I got to go back on and do a few spaces just because the normalcy bias is even stronger this time than it was last time.
And even though we made the spaces last year, I'm sure people weren't paying that much attention and they have no idea what they're walking into.
And the earlier, you know, what's going to happen, the, the more you personally have an advantage over the people you would naturally compete with.
Right.
So, uh, in 2020, there was a shortage of toilet paper because everyone was freaking out that they wouldn't have toilet paper.
They weren't, it wasn't, it wasn't dying from, from, uh, uh, a virus.
It was really that they, they would be stuck at home without toilet paper.
And I guess I can understand it's like a natural anxiety.
Right.
Okay.
You're raising your hand.
So, uh, dude, I'll, I'll put you up to speaker, but if it's like, um, if it's like a digression or something, uh, we're just going to not do that.
Right.
But I'll give you, uh, an invitation cause you keep flashing your hand.
So, uh, yeah.
Um, this is going to be a significantly, uh, because of where the, the transit was, the zero degrees areas.
Right.
Um, and the nature of Neptune and Saturn and anyhow, this is going to be a significantly more eventful year than 2020.
Like significantly.
And next year will be as well.
So while 2020 was like historically unprecedented, right.
Um,
it's not going to be like it was, you know, it's going to be worse.
the, the problems that we had supporting people, my feeding and, and housing people, because there were housing issues at that time.
Right.
They had to stop people from evicting.
They had to stop people from evicting people in the U S because in the middle of a, uh, what they believe to be right.
Like a, uh, a serious life-threatening pandemic, uh, landlords were, were evicting people.
And, um, you can't, you can't, uh, yeah, you can't make people different than they are.
Right.
So they had to stop that from happening.
All those problems, like the, um, supply issues and the price of gasoline and people being evicted and the lockdowns, like those were all the result of whatever the pandemic was.
Um, this is, um, a different situation because the, the supply shock is going to create those problems prior to the issues that will come from it.
The reason I say that is because Neptune and Saturn, Neptune conjunctions also can indicate pandemics.
So the first thing I had to tell you is, as bad as the oil and the war and the oil shock is, it's not only going to be the war and an oil shock.
I'm concerned.
I'm not making a prediction.
I'm voicing a concern and that concern is that, um, almost immediately following the, the conjunction within two weeks, which is very close.
Uh, we started to see this meningitis issue in, in the UK.
There are many reasons to be concerned about that.
And I can give you remote viewing related reasons, prophetic reasons.
I'm going to focus on the astrology right now, and then I'm going to talk about the oil supply shock, and then I'll come back to the meningitis.
However, I will point out that, uh, meningitis is swelling of the brain and the spinal column, the, the tissue around the brain and the tissue around the spinal column.
Swelling is ruled by Neptune, which is a weird thing to say.
Like there's a planet that rules swelling, but if you think about it, Neptune governs the tides in astrology, right?
Or is related to the tides.
It's basic archetypal, um, symbolism.
And swelling, right?
Is, is a form of tide, really.
So, the fact that this, um, this, illness became an issue at this time, that, that concerns me deeply.
And there, there's real reason to be concerned from a prophetic and a remote viewing standpoint.
Um, meningitis is not usually a pandemic.
Uh, it is, it's sometimes in Africa.
And this, uh, everything is so complicated.
So, because in hot, dry areas, it can spread through the air.
It can't in other areas.
So, if this was a cold and rainy year, we might not have much to be concerned about.
As you may be aware, um, a lot of areas are experiencing a massive heat wave and are very dry.
And that's sort of an odd coincidence.
Um, the other thing to think about, regardless of what your perspective is on what happened with the pandemic.
Uh, there is a, a sort of a concerted effort to confuse people and get them to not focus on the pathogenic nature of spike proteins.
So, and I'm not going to get, like, I'm not going to launch into something that's going to get everyone pissed off, right?
I'm just going to mention this, um, regardless, right, of whether you contract a virus that weakens your immune system or, uh,
you are exposed to that material in another way, right?
If the pathogenic aspect of that weakens your immune system,
then you could make certain inferences about the population's immune system.
It's highly unusual to have 29 people at one school get meningitis at the same time.
It does happen.
Like, people get meningitis, right?
Like, from the shower or whatever.
But we're all, or not all of us, but a lot of us are exposed to that bacteria.
And in most cases, our immune system fights it off.
So it is strange that they're suddenly concerned, right?
Concerned to the extent that they gave 6,000 people a dose of ciproflaxin, um, laxacin, whatever, um, cipro,
to try to make sure it didn't spread further.
But generally, it wouldn't.
So, uh, it's just very concerning.
However, I was talking, or I've been talking to a lot of people online about this,
because I can't shut my mouth or stop my fingers.
Um, one of the things you learn when you study this stuff, like, from a historical perspective,
the Earth's natural carrying capacity for human beings is about 600 million.
If you look back at, uh, the Roman Empire or, uh, Genghis Khan, right?
The period, uh, uh, middle ages where Genghis Khan was running around.
Um, you had, you know, prior to, right?
Anywhere between 200 and 600 million people on planet Earth.
And that's using agriculture and, um, you know, rudimentary technology.
The Romans were actually pretty advanced.
And they had, like, a very long supply chain.
So, as far as civilizations are concerned, right, that was a period where, um, they were able to use their technology prior to the Industrial Revolution to support a lot of people.
But it, it, you know, the maximum, mathematically speaking, from what I remember in my studies, is about 600 million.
Um, with the advent of coal, uh, you're able to use, uh, the energy generated by coal to multiply the amount of work that you're able to do as a, as an individual, as a society, as a business.
And, um, the term that they used to use, I don't know what term they use now.
I assume they've changed their term because the traditional term was energy slave.
Okay.
I, I understand that's in 2000 and 26, that's a very loaded, uh, term, but, uh, horsepower is another way of looking at it.
Right.
Um, it's a comparable term.
Um, and it's basically the amount of, um, the amount of work or effort that machines do for us.
So if you are, if you live in England or the UK, England or the UK, Jesus, if you live in the UK or the United States of America, uh, you have between 60 and 90, a multiplication of 60 and 90 horsepower, energy slaves, whatever the correct term is.
Um, it's as if you had 60 or 90 people working full-time to support you.
That's the multiplying factor that fossil fuels has, um, in, in generating, you know, prosperity and, and, uh, uh, uh, uh, all the, um, the surplus food and keeping our houses warm.
Uh, when you get it, not, that's because we have oil that wouldn't be possible under a coal civilization.
Coal enhances the carrying capacity of a society to about 2 billion, uh, or, or the planet to about 2 billion.
So if we went back to just using coal, we could, we could keep 2 billion people alive, uh, long-term, but we wouldn't really be able to do more than that.
Uh, oil.
Um, the prediction was always that oil would be able to, using oil and natural gas, we'd be able to support between 6 and 8 billion people.
And the first thing that's going to occur to everyone is, you know, we're, we're beyond 8 billion now.
That's not true.
Um, there, there have been arguments made for a long time that, um, just like some countries overestimate their oil reserves for status sake or to secure loans from the IMF.
Uh, other countries or the same countries in some cases, um, exaggerate their population figures for status and to secure loans and investment from foreign countries.
There are arguments by good arguments that the population in China, for instance, is much lower than they say it is, but it's absolutely certain that it's lower than what they say it is.
Right.
So they just wrote it down between a hundred and 300 million.
A lot of people don't know that.
Um, but they were forced to basically, um, as technology advanced and they compiled all this, um, data, they realized that provinces in inside China were inflating their population figures in order to take advantage of the government inside China, as opposed to, you know, taking advantage of foreign investors.
As a national policy, um, as a national policy, um, that that's been going on for the last couple of years.
People have known about it since the nineties, but that's been a topic of conversation for the last year or two.
Um, India, a few weeks ago, put out, um, some information saying that there was a, their productivity had been overstated 17 to 20%.
And one thing that, that, that, that, that could mean a number of things, but that's also a way of possibly saying that population was overestimated 17 to 20%, which would make sense.
We take for granted that everyone has our, um, our level of technology and our capacity.
Right.
Uh, and it's not a judgment, but people don't have to be afraid of starving death in the United States today.
So if you have a job or something, right, you have less incentive to be creative with the facts and figures on every level in our society that you might in another society, it's not a reflection on you or them as a person.
Because if we were in a situation where if we didn't have a job, you know, we might starve to death, then we might play fast and loose with the figures.
And that was like in our time as people who are a little older.
Right.
I would say that I, a millennial or generation Z is probably as fast and loose with figures and facts as any person in any other place.
Um, so yeah, uh, oil between six and 8 billion, um, is your maximum carrying capacity with oil and natural gas.
Uh, right now, um, the, the Strait of Cuomo is the crisis, right?
It shut down about 25% of the world's, uh, fossil fuels trading.
Oh, well, not get cold.
So about 25% of the oil and gas in the world is not on the market right now.
Uh, that would usually be produced.
It doesn't translate.
It doesn't like translate directly because you can make substitutions, right?
You can, and this will happen.
People will be forced to choose, you know, governments will be forced to choose.
What are we going to use this oil and gas for?
Right.
Are we going to use it to heat homes to, you know, uh, 70 degrees, or are we going to use it to heat homes to 68 degrees?
I'm going to take the rest and use it for something else.
Right.
So oil and gas are in 6,000 products.
Um, it's not like you just need it to fuel your car.
You need it to have a car, right?
You need it so you can have the plastic, um, and materials that, that make up your car or a computer.
You also need it so you can mine, right?
So you can mine the, the products that go into the car and the computer and the cell phone.
Um, but physically you need it for like, when you go to the store and you get like, I don't know, uh, granola.
I don't know, I don't get much, I don't buy much granola.
I don't know why I picked that.
So you get granola, it comes in a plastic bag, right?
And then you take that, you put it in another plastic bag.
You know?
Um, so just like simple things like packaging food can be an issue.
And we've already started to run out of plastic.
That's already happening on a global level, not a national level.
Um, another big thing no one is talking about 55%, I think it's roughly around there.
So I'm not making an exact statement.
I'm making an approximate statement, uh, about 55% of the material that makes up medicines is, uh, is, is, is, is derived from oil or gas feedstock.
So, uh, the pill that you're taking, the medicine itself, right?
The chemicals, like the basic material that they use, that they modify, right?
In order to make it into aspirin or Tylenol.
Tylenol is a good example.
So Tylenol is made out of oil, right?
Tylenol is chemically altered oil.
But so is metformin, metformin, whatever.
Um, and a number of essential, um, essential medications.
Most of our generic medications are made in India.
And India is having massive fuel shortages right now.
So the prediction is at least generic medications will be gone in six weeks if the war doesn't stop.
And we'll be experiencing massive global medication shortages.
That might not matter to anyone here or anyone who listens later, right?
Because maybe you're not on medication.
But a lot of us are.
And some of us are on medication we need to live.
And you can count on that medication being rationed or potentially not available, right?
So, like, the first thing that I would say in this situation is, like, probably the very first thing, find a way to get extra medication.
Right?
Get the 100 pills in the bottle as opposed to 30 pills.
Contact your insurance company.
Talk to your doctor and ask if they can write a prescription that you can pay for in cash to get extra medicine.
I'm not going to tell you to lie.
All right?
But I'm just going to say that, you know, it's, again, I'm not endorsing it.
But I'm saying, like, some people might contact the doctor and say, look, I lost.
You know, I lost this medicine and I need a refill.
If they're unable to get one.
And try to stay ahead of that.
Food.
Any type of goods, right?
It's not just the plastic.
It's not just the oil and gas that go into it.
Um, but it's the transportation, right?
So there's a, we, we, everyone here has been alive for this a few times.
Okay.
So 2008, I think it was early 2008.
It could have been 2007.
Right.
There was a, a huge spike in the price of oil.
And that is what caused the great recession.
That, that spike crashed the economy.
Um, we had this issue around 9-11, but it wasn't so much related to, uh, oil price shocks, but there was one, right?
And it had a massive, right?
We went into a recession.
Um, there was a, an oil price shock in the, in 1973 related to another Middle Eastern war, uh, leading to an oil embargo.
That, um, that oil embargo, uh, reduced the supply of oil about half as much as this one is reducing it on a percentage basis.
So it was like half the size of this oil shock so far.
And that was when people were waiting in line for, uh, at least in the United States, people were waiting in line for hours, um, to refill their, their gas tank, right?
In their car.
And there were, when I was growing up, there were photos of the cars going down the street.
Um, but what a lot of people don't realize about that is the reason that a lot of people didn't die was because there was a, um, there was a, there was a, there was a fear in the sixties and seventies that there were going to be like hundreds of millions of people were going to die from starvation.
And there was a, and there was a guy, Norman Borlaug, Norman Borlaug is like the, the hero of human history.
More people are alive because of Norman Borlaug, I think than anyone else who's ever lived.
There's like one other guy who invented, I think something, but Norman Borlaug was, um, he hybridized wheat and corn and stuff like that.
He was, he was, um, uh, botanist, I guess, who hybridized cereal grains and he improved the, like the productive, um, the production of like, uh, corn and wheat by many factors, like a factor of, I don't know, at least four, um, by shortening the stems.
Like he had like this, it would shorten the stems.
It would increase the production of the seed, whatever.
Um, if Norman Borlaug hadn't lived and started, uh, the green revolution in the sixties, hybridizing these, um, wheat and corn and rice, uh, the productive capacity for cereal grains would not have increased to the point where people could, um, survive during the oil crisis in 1973.
You know, I, most of us, I think are old enough to remember, um, are old enough to remember like the famines in Africa and being a thing on TV, um, where they would show the poor starving kids in order to raise money to help Africa and help the starving people.
That was still a run-on effect of the oil spike in 1973.
Right.
And the only reason those famines weren't significantly worse, they, they anticipated two to 300 million people starving.
Uh, at that time, uh, uh, oil and, uh, natural gas are the feedstock for fertilizers.
So, um, and, and some are also produced as a by-product of the, the, uh, of, uh, drilling for oil.
So it's not entirely a feedstock related issue, but it is true that 50% or more of the world's fertilizers are offline right now as well.
Um, obviously we're just heading into the planting season now.
So a lot of people are saying, you know, perhaps we won't have food shortages on a global level until autumn.
I don't know if that's an accurate assessment, but what I do know is that it's, it's certain, unless this stops right now, and it's not going to stop, that we are going to have real food shortages this fall.
Um, it's not going to be the same in the U S and the UK as it is going to be in other areas, but it's going to be tough.
Um, and that's, that's just what's happening now without second order of events, second order, um, effects occurring in our countries.
As a result of the tension of this crisis, right?
So like what could happen?
All right.
So the, a reasonable ceiling price for gasoline is about four times, four times, 400% what it is today.
Now it's going to vary significantly depending on where one is.
All right.
Some areas that might not be as bad because there are areas I know in Europe and also there are states in the United States where the taxes are so high that it, it, it, it accounts for a large portion of the price.
It is possible that the pressure will cause, will force the governments to relent and suspend those taxes.
In which case in those areas, the price of gas won't go up four times.
It might go up two times or three times.
Right.
The price of diesel will also go up that amount.
So those transportation costs, cost of producing the food because agriculture is very energy intensive.
You have to, you know, use machines, you've got to irrigate, you've got to use trucks to move the food from the farm to the warehouse, from the warehouse to the bigger warehouse, from that warehouse across the country to another warehouse and then to the store.
And every time, right, someone's got to fuel up their vehicle to do it.
So massive increases in the price of food.
Again, it won't be the same everywhere.
Right.
Like already in Southeast Asia, they're having these problems.
Already.
They're having shortages of cooking gas in India.
They're having, they're, they're being asked not to drive in a lot of countries in the Middle East, unless they have to, and Southeast Asia, they're going to reduce work weeks in countries in Southeast Asia.
I don't know about in the Mideast at this point.
So what that adds up to that a lot of people, I think, don't get, and this is important to the planning, right?
This is the very most important thing.
The normalcy bias that we're all experiencing is going to impact our ability to react effectively in a way to help us.
And this is why I'm doing this.
And I'll do three more.
You know, I don't know if I will help anybody.
I don't know if it's possible to help anybody.
I think the, on, on social media, I think the purpose of social media, not me particularly, I'm not, I'm not paranoid saying people like me, people who, who bring this information that isn't, isn't, isn't, isn't in a social norm.
Right.
I think the purpose of social media is to whittle us away to, to slow or inhibit the spread of that information.
Like if I was talking to you one-on-one prior to the age of the internet, I might be much more convincing than if you're looking up at that board and you're seeing like, you know, UFOs and, and, uh, you know, angel numbers and whatever.
And it, it relegates everything someone says to just another form of entertainment as opposed to important information.
Okay.
It's like a, an immune system to stop the spread of important information.
But if any person who will react and make plans, right.
Earlier than other people, they have a selective advantage.
Okay.
Um, like I said, with pharmaceuticals, there's going to be a pharmaceutical shortage.
Now you can quibble about the morality of making sure that you and your family get their medicine first, but the majority of us are going to do that.
If we can, if we, if we really believe we know what's coming food, the price of food is going to the fucking roof, through the roof, gas, through the roof.
Many areas of the world, you're absolutely going to see rationing, um, this summer.
Now, like this administration, the U S is not going to want to do that.
Right.
Uh, there's this idea that we are completely energy independent.
That's not true.
Um, we are potentially completely energy independent in the U S and this is probably true in Europe as well.
We deal with a lot of, um, imagination.
Um, so there's a lot of like imaginary money.
Right.
Um, so like, and this is not getting political.
I'm just saying like earlier, like last year, we were told that other countries, you know, had invested trillions and trillions of dollars in our economy.
We were told that, but in reality, they had just said, they were going to do it sitting around a table.
And then people took that information and went on the news or went in on the front of the camera and made statements.
Um, South Korea has invested a trillion dollars in this economy.
Right.
It was imaginary money, hypothetical money.
Maybe it'll happen, um, in the future, but that money's not here.
Okay.
In that same way, America has the potential to be energy and resource independent.
That that's true.
That's potential in reality, uh, when we're not, and there are beyond like the amount of oil that's pumped out of the ground, for instance, a natural gas.
There is an issue with, um, there is an issue with, um, there is an issue with refiners and, and how the oil is refined because, um, refineries are generally built to refine a certain type of oil, right?
There's like heavy, sour crude that you get from Venezuela, whereas light, sweet crude that you get from Texas.
Apparently the oil in the Middle East is so valuable because it's like the easiest oil to refine.
Um, so it's like the oil that if you, if you could have any other oil in the world, you would want that oil.
So when they build these refineries, right, like they build them for a certain type of oil.
You can't just pump the other type of oil in it.
Now, this is how crazy it gets, right?
You build the refinery where you ship the oil.
You don't refine it before you ship it in most cases or in a third party nation.
So if you, um, if you, uh, pump oil out of the ground in Venezuela, generally speaking,
you send it to China.
And the reason you send it to China is the refineries that refined that type of oil are
in China.
They're not in Venezuela.
The same is true for our oil.
And it's great because it guarantees business, right?
If you're in the oil business, this is great because, you know, like if you're in the Venezuelan
oil business, like China has got to buy your oil.
So that's great.
You've locked it down.
Now, um, that doesn't help you, right?
So we do not have the capacity to refine all the energy that we need.
We don't in this country.
At some point we could, but we don't today.
Um, now all these until, until we nationalize, right?
Like this is, it's a free world.
And so they can, they can, or it's a free country at least.
Oh, okay.
That's not equivalent.
You can sell your oil to whomever you want, as long as they're not on some list.
So at, you know, as of today, uh, if Japan wants to buy American oil and they're willing
to pay more than Americans, American companies can send it to Japan.
There is no law or executive order telling them they have to keep it here.
They're thinking about banning the export of oil.
They are at least certain varieties of oil in the U S and they're thinking about it everywhere
in the world that has oil.
Um, but you know, right now, um, they don't have to send it to us.
No one, no one is forcing anyone to keep the oil here.
So we actually have significantly less, right?
Because oil is fungible and you can sell it to anyone.
Uh, at some point, they're probably going to be in the export.
Now that's going to really screw things up.
That's not going to make things better.
It's going to screw things up because again, we don't have the capacity to refine that oil
here.
It'll be a political mover maneuver, right?
With economic consequences.
Secondly, our companies have business relationships and, you know, they sell that oil to these other
countries to support their corporation, right?
And to support their, their drilling, pay for it.
And if you say, look, you can't export.
It's not like they're like, all right, Hey, Bob doesn't, I can't send it to Bob.
So I'm going to give it to bill.
I'm going to sell it to bill.
Like they don't have that.
They don't have it lined up.
They don't have like, you know, um, a guaranteed buyer.
And there will be one, but it will increase the speed that the oil shock hits us.
And that's the problem.
We live the level of complexity here is, is to the extent that every second order effect
is influencing or accelerating another issue, another problem.
So there are people who are very knowledgeable, who are like, well, we're going to have problems
with food this fall.
And then you're going to have some real problems in early 27th.
No, this, this crisis is going to be on us right now.
If this was the pandemic, we're in February in pandemic time.
Right.
So next month, we're going to see like some big changes in the world.
Guaranteed by the summer, right by July, if this continues, um, and, and I, I think there's
reason to believe it will like, we're going to be, we're going to have a serious global
crisis on our hands.
Like, so right now, you know, there are Asian nations that are, um, you know, a couple of
weeks away from a Cuba scenario where they lose all their power, right.
Where they, everything shuts down.
Like in those, in those.
Scenarios, people begin to starve.
And we're very close to that right now.
I know in Europe, you guys, uh, or I guess, I don't think there's anyone here from Germany.
Um, maybe, I don't know.
Um, you know, I know that you have, um, or they're going to be specific issues, right?
Luckily it's a hot year.
Um, but it's still a point in time where some people need to heat their homes.
Right.
And that's going to be an issue.
Um, if this goes on until autumn, it's going to be a real issue.
Um, heating Europe is going to be a real crisis.
Um, but during that period in time, like they're going to shut down businesses.
So, uh, today, uh, some UN agency, I don't think it's a world health organization.
It's an international energy.
Don't quote me on what agency it was.
Cause I was just reading this before I, I, um, I started the space, but of course, like
I was, my mind was on something else.
Uh, but they have already issued, uh, 10, 10, a 10 phase, 10 step, uh, lockdown advisory
to countries.
So that, that was today.
Like I knew that was coming, right?
Like I knew it was coming last year, right?
From looking at the astrology and the, and the remote viewing.
But as soon as this started, I said, okay, we're, we're on that time frame now to the
lockdowns or de facto lockdowns.
A lot of people are in denial about that.
They did put it out today.
The advisory, they don't want people driving.
They want, you know, everyone's thermostat being lowered by, you know, if you have the,
um, the computer thermostat, they want everyone's thermostat being turned down, um, by the government
to 66.
They have like a list.
Um, they want to alternate driving to every other day.
Like that's coming.
This definitely coming to the UK.
That's coming to the UK probably next month.
I'm surprised they're not doing it already.
Cause this is like an opportunity for some people, um, who have that agenda and it's coming
to the U S as well.
And that's where people are real.
Like, particularly people who are, um, right-wing populists are like completely in denial about
that.
They're like, no, no, we got our guy and he's not going to let that happen, but it's definitely
going to happen if this continues.
Uh, when you are in these types of wars, um, there is rationing.
There wasn't world war II.
And we've had these wars since then that weren't as, um, weren't as serious.
Uh, what a lot of people don't recognize, there's been a tremendous amount, there's a tremendous
amount of Iranian propaganda, Russian propaganda, Chinese propaganda.
There's also been a tremendous amount of, um, anti-Iranian propaganda.
So, um, Iran has been marginalized and it's been marginalized through the use of language
in the media to the point where people don't realize what Iran is.
On a, in a real productive sense, like bar of steel for bar of steel, barrel of oil for
barrel of oil.
Iran is the fourth largest economy on earth.
There's, um, there's a, an adage that says, if you can make cars, you can build missiles.
So when you think about countries that it's going to be, you know, difficult or, or countries
that are going to have the capacity to fight, uh, and, and possibly win a long war, you look
at the countries that build cars or Russia builds cars, U S builds cars, right?
Um, Iran builds cars so they can take those automobile factories and repurpose them if they want to.
Right.
Iraq didn't build cars, Vietnam didn't build cars.
The industrial base is, is vastly larger.
The size of the country is vastly larger, right?
Vietnam and Iraq are tiny compared to Iran.
Iran has 90 million people and it's mountainous and mountainous territory is very, very difficult
to invade.
Um, the Persian Gulf, um, is, uh, for the most part, um, has cliffs on either side and over
the last 40, 50 years, um, the Iranian government, as well as other organizations have been digging
into those cliffs and preparing for this exact scenario.
So if you sail a ship into that, uh, into the Straits of Homo's, you are in a shooting
gallery.
Um, and you will note that we're, as we're trying to encourage other navies to patrol the
Straits of Homo's, we are not patrolling the Straits of Homo's right now.
And, you know, if, if we could, we would, but it's a shooting gallery, right?
It's not safe for our ships or anyone else's.
Um, one thing that I saw someone write today, which is interesting, um, you know, the Iran-Iraq
war began in 1980 and, um, or around 1980 and in 1980, uh, the Iraqis wanted to sue for
peace and the Iranians said, no, and they kept fighting for eight years.
Right.
Because Iraq had invaded them.
And when we were growing up, when I was growing up, uh, they would talk a lot on the news about,
um, the fact that, you know, the U S was supplying Iraq with weapons, which we were at
the time and, um, the Iranians didn't have, um, comparable, uh, weapons of technology,
which they do now.
Um, but at that time, and this, I'm sorry, this is, you know, um, uh, trigger, trigger
warning, um, you know, they would round up groups of kids and give them a plastic key
that said, you know, key to heaven.
And they would have them run across minefields and that's how they cleared the minefields.
And they went on and did this for eight years after they could have stopped the war.
This is not a, these are not, um, cowardly people and Iran is not, um, Iraq.
It's not Vietnam.
So, uh, this seems like it might be a case of, uh, politicians buying the, the company line,
buying the, the propaganda line and underestimating the, the strength of their opponent, uh, prior
to beginning a war against them.
Or there is a second, um, line of thinking and it's very Machiavellian, but the line of
thinking goes, right.
Uh, the U S may be in the best civil situation globally in order to successfully weather this
situation.
So if you were Machiavellian enough to discount the fact that this is going to affect hundreds
of millions of lives, if you thought this was inevitable, no matter what you said, this
is inevitable.
This is a point in time in which if you choose your battles at this time, it's, you know,
you might anticipate the U S will come out better than anyone else.
Certainly this is related to containing China, right?
Um, I know what I can tell you from, you know, we can look at the astrology, we can look at
the prophecy right now, astrology, right.
Um, right now, Pluto is transiting China's ascendant.
So, um, this is a period where, um, China is particularly dangerous.
Um, from a remote viewing standpoint, um, intuitive underground had made the prediction from their
session data that, um, China would achieve technological parity with the U S or appear to achieve technological
parity with the U S.
And following that would be a global crisis that would, uh, eventually lead to, um, kinetic
action.
I don't know how much of the news you guys all pay attention to with like foreign news, but
like first we had the drones.
Remember, I don't know.
Um, we have, um, some people from the UK here.
So we had, uh, some drones, well, I guess the drones are flying around the UK too.
No one knew where the drones are coming from.
And they were flying around New Jersey, particularly for a long time, but they've been in Sweden.
I think they were in the UK.
Um, the accusation was they were Chinese and they used a certain type of technology that,
um, the point of flying them around was to make clear they could fly them around.
Um, China, uh, succeeded in creating fusion reactors.
They released that news a month or two ago, a couple months ago.
No one talked about it, but they have China is, is now capable.
Building fusion reactors.
Um, or at least according to China, they are right.
Oh, where is this?
Hold on guys.
I'm getting, uh, my phone is sending me off on.
Okay.
Back.
Uh, they have released, I don't know if anyone has noticed how many medical breakthroughs
they've been talking about recently.
Like China has figured out solutions to, um, things like arthritis and vision loss.
And it's almost as if, um, this period of time is, uh, was intended to be a coming out party
for them.
We've, we've done it.
We've made it.
We've got to the point where, where, you know, we have this level of technology.
Well, that, that's a threat.
I mean, from, um, from a strictly geopolitical standpoint.
Right.
And, uh, China themselves, like they internally, at least if the information that the public,
the American public can find is accurate.
You know, they have long predicted they could defeat the U S in a war by 2027.
So if you were at the point where you believe this was inevitable, right.
And if you looked at, um, what's going on in Ukraine and, you know, as a potential precursor
to a Taiwan event, right.
Like things going more global, um, then it would make sense to begin containing them, containing
China.
So the first thing you do is find out where they get their oil, right.
Cause that's the most important part of containment.
So you'd say, well, a big chunk of it comes from Venezuela.
Okay.
So what are you gonna do about that?
A big chunk of it comes from Iran.
What are you gonna do about that?
Iran and Venezuela combined, that's 50% of the oil.
That means their industrial capacity is reduced by 50%, which means their ability to, um, manufacture
the items, you know, based on the technology that they've developed is significantly reduced.
Oh, they also figured out how to make the best computer chips in the world.
As good as the, the ones that Taiwan makes, but Taiwan makes them with a machine that's
only made by one company in Holland and no one else could make that machine.
And shortly before things started going crazy geopolitically, the Chinese had recreated that
machine.
So they can now make the same quality chips, apparently.
So that, that was a, uh, successful prediction.
Um, when you look at the things that are going on with, uh, North America, right.
Again, I'm not talking right or wrong.
I'm just talking about how things were.
Um, you know, I'm not political and I understand that people would get very upset about things.
Um, when you look at the nations and areas that have been in the news in the U S and probably
in the news globally around the U S, um, they're all potential beach heads, right?
So, you know, for instance, Venezuela was a potential beachhead in Northern South America.
And that means in, in the event of, uh, of a war with China, China could land soldiers
there and those soldiers could get from Venezuela to the U S by land, right?
Uh, Cuba, um, not as much of a beachhead, but definitely a staging ground, uh, Greenland,
right?
The Mercado projection maps that we all grew up with make Greenland look like it's between
Europe and the U S, but it's not, it's on top of Canada.
So it's between the U S and in Russia really is, you know, and the Arctic circle.
So it's an extreme beachhead.
Um, you know, the, the, the, the Russians, the Chinese would come right over into Greenland.
Um, the cartels, uh, Mexican cartels, Colombian cartels, Venezuelan cartels are all tied in
to, um, the Chinese and the Russians who either, or, um, um,
and have been for years, which also makes sense.
Now, some of them are tied into the U S, right?
Um, the U S has irregular forces.
We have Syrian militia groups.
We support, we have Kurdish militia groups, militia groups, we support, et cetera, as do
the Chinese and the Russians.
That's part of being a global power, apparently, unfortunately.
So, um, you know, prior to Iran, Venezuela, and Cuba, Cuba is, I'm deeply conflicted about
Cuba.
I don't, as part, part of being non-political is that I'm, I don't believe in being a defeatist.
I don't believe in, um, I'm not overly critical of one specific government, including my own.
Like I'm critical of everyone, but I also realized like, I'm not, the governments do what governments
do.
I'm not at that level, right?
I'm not at the level where I'm consulted by governments.
I'm not tied into that at all.
So I don't, I don't, um, I don't read like seditious stuff and things like that.
I don't have any interest in that at all.
None.
I do feel conflicted about Cuba because I mean, those people are going to starve and
I, I don't know to what extent Cuba needs to be ground down.
I don't know.
They're starting to make concessions, but clearly like they're going to be in American territory
at the end of this.
Um, well, that's, it's, it's based on, it's all containment.
It's all preparing for this larger war.
That's why they're willing to, um, in my opinion, uh, create this price shock.
I think they underestimated it significantly.
And if it is to be believed, there were politicians who did not believe that, uh, Iran would close
the Straits of Hormuz.
I think they thought they were cowards and that if they could just scare the shit out of
them, they wouldn't do it.
They wouldn't do it.
Like they're, they would be too worried about being killed themselves.
So they wouldn't, you know, dare shut the Straits of Hormuz.
There was a fantasy.
It's done now.
Um, so what happens if they fix this?
Like what if it ends tomorrow?
Well, if it ends tomorrow, it's six to nine months until the normalcy returns.
There'll be a period of three to six months where things continue to get worse.
Supply chains have been broken and impacted.
You know, you get that oil back on the ocean.
Who's going to go to first, right?
Or you get the gas blowing again.
Where's it going to go first?
It can't go everywhere at one time.
Um, so you're still going to have pockets of crisis getting, getting worse during that
period.
Um, if it continues, which it's definitely continued through April.
Um, it's probably going to continue on some level for a lot longer than that.
Um, you know, so what are we looking at?
Okay.
So, um, the astrology says that we're looking at a two year issue.
That doesn't mean things will return.
The astrology wouldn't say where things are going to return to normal.
It would mean that this particular set of crises would resolve somewhat in that period.
Um, eschatologically speaking, uh, what people, if you study comparative eschatology, and very
few people do, you find that.
Everyone has prophecies and predictions, and they tend to fit together well, like puzzle
piece.
The main difference between the prophecies and predictions of the Hopi or Northern South
American tribes or Buddhist prophecies and predictions, which exist, or, um, you know,
the Muslim prophecies or, you know, Christian prophecies is at the end of the prediction,
whoever's making it, like their people are going to wind up in charge, basically, or on
top.
Um, but when you get to like the, the details of events, oftentimes it's, everyone is talking
about the same details from different perspectives.
Uh, so Buddhist prophecies and predictions clearly, um, this, this timing issues, we got to set
the timing issues aside because there are reasons for the timing issue.
So if you have any familiarity with these prophecies, you got to just take the timing issues and
set them aside.
Um, so Buddhist Shambhala prophecies, um, basically relate to, uh, Russia and or China, uh, fighting
the West, right?
They have at that point, like there's a, a King basically over the entire world.
So a world leader of the West and you want, he, he winds up, um, duking it out, uh, with,
um, with the Chinese and the Russians.
Now in a prophetic standpoint, like the U S president would fit that role perfectly.
Um, particularly if Iran was defeated, um, but if you look at it, you know, um, if they say
like a King over all the Abrahamic religions, like Saudi Arabia is fighting with us now, right?
United Arab Emirates.
I mean, pretty much if you, if you look around the world outside of, especially after they get
done, right outside of Russia and China, everyone is, is pretty much going to be lined up with
NATO.
The brakes thing is not panning out.
Um, the, I don't want to appropriate, I don't want to get anyone pissed off by appropriating
Islamic prophecies.
There are definitely, um, individuals with an interest in Islamic prophecy who see it unfolding
right now.
Um, I can say that the Islamic last battle begins in Iran and moves to Syria.
Um, no one has come forward to claim to be the Islamic Messiah yet, but I anticipate it's
going to happen if this continues for more than another month or two.
Um, certainly like the, those prophecies talk about a lot of population displacement in the
Middle East.
And if it's the desalination plants, um, most Middle Eastern countries, they don't have water
for their people without those desalination plants.
Like they use like 40,000% as much water, some of them as they have.
Um, so if Iran hits those desalination plants or makes a habit of hitting them, then you're
going to see like a large population.
Um, uh, you're gonna see a lot of people moving around very quickly, like shocking number of
people moving around very quickly.
Um, there are a number of, uh, independent, well, there are like hundreds independent profits
history.
And most of them who talk about this specific period, like it all, all the pieces fit together.
Like some famous ones would be like, uh, I, I, the pronunciation is my pronunciation of foreign
words is garbage.
L-O-A-L-O-S-E-R-L-O-M-E-R was a German, uh, Mother Shifton.
She was in the UK.
Um, Baba Banya was in, um, I think Bulgaria.
I'm a little off on that one, right?
Um, yeah, I mean, the reason I, I bring up eschatology is that profits, historically
speaking, were remote viewers or clairvoyants.
They had their own form of training, which was often like repeating religious mantras, stuff
that like would still work today.
It's not the same as, um, as remote viewing, but they had some individuals who were very,
very skilled, um, clairvoyants and they were hitting the same targets.
So, uh, if you look at like orthodoxy, right?
Like, um, orthodox priests, not everyone, but there are still orthodox priests who make
prophecies now, um, Mormon, right?
Um, Mormon prophets and individuals in the Mormon church were making prophecies until fairly
right recently.
Um, as Christianity, and this is, that's very complicated and it's the subject of my last
space, but, uh, uh, Christianity went from being a prophet centered, um, community.
They, they, who we call, um, what we refer to as, um, uh, the evangelists, uh, were, were
known as prophets in their time.
And we have documents that demonstrate that.
So when you look at, um, like the Bible, when it talks about the apostles going out and,
you know, going and speaking in tongues and, uh, prophesying, right?
They, they were, they were.
And so they were received as, as Jewish slash Christian prophets when they would go places.
Right.
So it was, it was a living tradition.
As time went on, the church changed and that behavior became unacceptable.
It's still something there have been monks and, um, nuns who, who've prophesized quite
a bit, um, you know, over the last few thousand years.
Uh, but it's, it's, it's discouraged.
It's frowned upon.
And, and probably for good reason, because oftentimes it's just, uh, someone making something up.
Once people stop practicing the, the yogic practices, the meditation practices, the mantras that allow
them to hone their clairvoyant abilities, then you do wind up with just people making stuff
up, right?
But it's become in, in, in modern Protestantism, it's become like a dogmatic thing that the prophets
in the Bible and, um, early Christian prophets, right?
Like they, they weren't using an ability.
They were reading a letter.
Like God was writing a letter and then the prophets would read it basically.
And that's not what, in my opinion, was happening.
In my opinion, they were, they were clairvoyants.
Um, that doesn't mean there wasn't a religious aspect of what they were doing.
Cause I believe there was, I just think they were using an innate ability, just like, you
know, if, uh, if you were a priest in a church reading the Bible, you're using your actual
eyes, right?
That's your ability.
Um, in that way, they were using clairvoyance in order to get that, retrieve that information.
And when you look at old Christian prophecies, they're very much in line with what we're talking
about.
Right.
So there's been like a ton of, um, creative eschatological interpretation of Christian prophecies
in the Bible that add quite a bit to the text in order to explain it.
I'm not, this isn't a, uh, a space about the book of revelations.
Um, however, what I'm going to point out is, um, there is good reason to believe that some
of the events that are happening right now are found in that text.
Um, when you look at the actual words, uh, when you, you know, take the actual text where
the Strong's concordance and the Greek words and read what they say, as opposed to listening
to a long sort of historical mash of interpretations, then there are clearly connections.
It's, it's, it's not popular to say that it's, um, and there's a reason, right?
Like, uh, without digressing too much, like even in Christian circles, it's not popular
to refer to the book of revelations because during the Iraq war, the U S government, um, represented
the war in the Mideast as being the events of revelations.
Um, and they do this whenever the U S they, they, they, they use religious imagery whenever
U S soldiers are fighting a protracted war because they, we count on the certain demographics
in this country.
Um, you know, more, more of our military is drawn from evangelical or Baptist, um, Southern
and Midwestern, um, young men that demographic.
Um, and so it's motivational for them.
So when the Iraq war was going on, uh, they leaned very heavily into, um, the book of revelations,
um, they convinced a large percentage of the, um, the Southern, um, Baptist evangelical, um, Pentecostal
community that was, you know, that, that, that, that, that was happening, right.
That, that was the actual Armageddon battle, even though Iraq is not in the book of revelation
that I'm aware of.
I mean, I guess the Euphrates river is okay.
So, um, they convinced them that was happening when it didn't turn out to be revelations,
when it turned out to be this complete train wreck.
Um, and at the end of it, the Lord hadn't returned.
Um, the evangelical community sort of stopped paying attention to revelations and started
listening to new age ish, questionable prophets, people like Chris Bledsoe, all right.
For the UFO people here, or, um, the Trump prophet guy, uh, Kim, whatever, he had like a mullet
and he would do music and he would talk about Trump years before Trump was elected president.
Like they switched to those.
That was their version of prophecy, non-biblical, um, highly questionable, uh, stuff.
So they, they don't feel comfortable with the book of revelations.
Okay.
So this is why I brought that up, um, on top of this, the lockdowns, the oil shock, you
know, we're going to see shortages.
Uh, we're going to see extreme limitations in a person's mobility.
So this is something we talked about last year, you know, particularly in the fall, I did
a couple of spaces on it.
I said, look, you know, use this opportunity to do things you want to accomplish because
going forward, right.
The intersection of crises and new technology is going to limit your mobility.
Your physical mobility is going to be limited.
Your ability to get from one place to another on an airplane is going to be limited.
Your ability to drive is going to be limited.
And your career mobility is going to be limited because of the advance of artificial intelligence
and the, um, the shocks coming as the result of the Saturn, uh, Neptune, uh, conjunction.
Right.
So, um, I said, you know, do it now.
If you want to do it, do it now.
If you want to go on vacation, go now.
Right.
Because you're, you're going to get locked down again.
And this time it's going to have a permanent effect on your life.
You know, again, people tune into these spaces for entertainment.
So everyone sort of went and just kept going with the life.
And oftentimes I would run into people who come to all my spaces and I would try to talk
to them about them and they wouldn't recollect anything that happened in one of my spaces.
So I don't even know why they would put it on.
I guess maybe I got to tell you the honest truth.
Like I find my voice a little annoying, so I would never put my voice on in the background
just to have like background sound and not listen to it.
But I understand that because I have put spaces on in the background and, you know, just had
it as like background noise or every once in a while someone would say something stupid
and I'd yell at the phone.
Right.
So I get it.
Um, I just don't know why anyone would do that with me particularly.
Um, I would pick somebody who's more articulate, uh, and had a, you know, a more soothing voice.
Um, uh, sometimes when I get worked up, I sound like one of those aliens from Mars attacks.
Um, God, can't even imagine listening to that recreational.
So, uh, yeah, uh, so shortages and, um, and limitations of mobility, but, you know, career
stuff too, because they're going to put everyone on a partial work, but work from home, work
less hours.
If the war continues, if the oil shock continues, there probably won't be any work or very little
work in the winter because you get a heat office buildings or whatever.
So they'll, they will shut down factories, they'll shut down offices, they'll shut down
schools.
Right.
If this oil shock continues, no one's kid is going to school, um, in December of 2026.
Uh, I don't even know if they would do it from, from home, to be honest.
Uh, maybe, uh, they tried that last time.
So maybe they would do it this time.
I guess they would have to do something.
Um, but basically everything that happened in the lockdown, uh, but more intense.
I know that in England, they're already starting to talk about the morality of heating someone's
house.
So they want to set everyone's thermostats on 66 because it's immoral to heat your house
to 71.
Now to my American mind, that is a batshit crazy thing.
And we definitely have had people like bureaucrats and politicians in our country who agree with
stuff like that, but they've never been able to do anything like that because the majority
of us think it's batshit crazy.
And we don't agree that it's immoral to heat your home, uh, but it's possible that they're
going to start using that language here as well and talk about the morality of, um, of doing
things like heating the house and driving, et cetera.
I assume with this administration in office, um, there'll be a resistance in the U S to these
lockdowns.
One of the things that remote viewing shows us, and I'm not taking a political position
nor am I wishing anything to happen.
Um, however, uh, the majority of remote viewers that I have, whose work I have looked into tend
to agree that this administration is here for a good time and not for a long time.
And, um, it would not be surprising if there was a transition to power at some point.
Um, and we have to use our imaginations here, but, uh, if for instance, the whole world was
reacting in one way, but our, our leaders were reacting in a different way that might lead
to a problem.
Um, this is all hypothetical.
I don't wish anything.
I don't have any political anything.
And I don't wish anything to happen.
And anyone, it's not my world there, their world is not my world.
So I'm not being seditious.
I'm just saying that's, that's something that has come up.
Um, and like, if we were talking about this last year, I wouldn't use a, um, a qualifier
and say, I'm not being seditious, but because we're clearly entering a, the global stage of
this global war and because we're clearly going to have restrictions imposed on us, you can
anticipate the speech restrictions to be a just as great, if not, um, greater this summer on
if we continue in this war, then, then not going to, um, they're not going to want people
talking about it, right?
Criticizing it.
Um, that, yeah, so that would be something then the food crisis will happen by this fall.
If not earlier, medicine crisis is six weeks from now.
It starts food prices are going to shoot for the root through the roof, through the roof.
Um, along with the gasoline prices, like that's going to happen.
That's already starting to happen here.
Like, I don't know if anyone knows this, but in the U S the U S average price of vegetables
went up, um, 44%.
Uh, you know, we, it seems like people don't pay as much attention to that.
I know I, I used to like to, I'm fat as fuck, dude.
I'm huge guys or whatever.
Um, I don't know what the collective people, friends, friends, yeah, I'm friends.
I am, I'm a big guy and, uh, I used to enjoy eating salads, but I, you know, and I would
feel good about it cause I would be doing my part to try to slim down a little bit too.
Um, but a salad, uh, pre-made salad in, in, in Massachusetts right now starts at $8 at a
supermarket and that's lettuce.
Okay.
Lettuce used to be the cheapest thing you could possibly get.
So the price of fruits and vegetables are going through the roof.
Grains rely heavily on, um, um, on fossil fuels.
And down the line from grains is of course, cattle, right?
So meat, um, that it's going to be very expensive.
Rain is going to be very expensive.
So like we have a society that tells us that it's immoral to prepare, right?
Some people have that belief.
I don't hold that belief, but some people do.
Uh, it used to be that you would be made fun of and called a prepper.
Now I think there are more people who are comfortable with being made fun of and called preppers.
Um, it's a good time to think about that, right?
And preparing for yourself.
And so, uh, preparing to take care of yourself and your family.
I, I am, this is how I feel about it.
I feel that maintaining mobility is important during times of crisis.
I think for the most part, all of us have had like the crises that have happened in the world during our lives.
Probably not.
Maybe, I don't think anyone here, but maybe one of you, I don't know.
Um, have not led to us having to physically move from one place to another to avoid the, the crisis or the effects of the crisis.
Sooner or later, that's going to change.
The pressure from this, um, right.
Along with the like foreign propaganda and all the crazy shit, like our government's extremely competent.
And I trust them to be able to, you know, of, of any government on earth, I trust our government here in the United States of America to be able to head off as much trouble as possible.
That's legitimate.
In the last 20 years, 25 years, I have seen evidence, you know, in the news and evidence, the remote viewing and other that, that they are very, very good.
At solving problems before we even know they exist.
That having been said, we have a lot of crazy people in this country now, right?
And I know you do in Europe too.
And those crazy people look for excuses and, you know, sometimes they succeed at derailing trains or, you know, blowing up bridges.
Sometimes they succeed at setting fires.
So that's one of the things the remote viewing is very clear about.
And I think the astrology would agree with it, which is danger of destruction through fire.
All right.
And you don't want to talk about this in public.
Like one of the reasons I'm going to not be giving space, I'm not going to be giving space is about this, right?
So you don't want to create, um, copycat effect to give people ideas, et cetera.
Um, but we all know that there were, well, I don't know, maybe we, maybe we don't.
So like last year or the year before, whenever that Los Angeles fire was right, there were people running around.
Maybe they didn't start the original fire, but there were people running around setting fire at all kinds of shit.
I found a bunch of people doing that.
They videotaped a bunch of people doing that.
If they videotaped a dozen people in Los Angeles starting fires, then there were a hundred doing it.
Right.
So that's something to be concerned about.
If you live in an urban area, the, the next thing I would say is, you know, I'd say get food.
Uh, if you can stock up on a little extra gas, you should probably do that.
If you want to have your maintaining mobility, although you may live in a place where gas never stops being sold.
It could be sold for $15 a gallon, right?
Or higher, I guess, in Europe, right?
Uh, medicines in advance.
Stock up on that.
Um, expect, right?
Expect this is going to be very, very serious.
Expect that if this were to continue, right?
Um, hundreds of millions of people experience hunger.
If this continues, that's not a, that's not hyperbole.
Okay.
And if this war continues to expand, right?
The first modern war was the civil war, right?
World war one was arguably the second.
Although you can say there was a war in Prussia that was arguably the second.
World war one was a good follow-up on the American civil war.
And 10 times as many people were killed.
Okay.
And in world war two, 10 times as many people as world war one in, in, in battle.
I know there was a discrepancy with the civilian.
Okay.
That's because of technological advances.
If, if we fought a war like that today, all right, based on that historical precedent, we'd be looking at around 700 million people dying in that war.
I know it's crazy to say that, but that's, that's the truth, right?
If this problem isn't solved, like if Iran attacks those desalination plants and continues doing it, you'd be looking at 300 million people without water.
Right?
And if this fertilizer and oil shortage continues, then you're looking at a 25% or greater reduction in the amount of food on earth.
Yeah, it's definitely, we could ration, right?
And a fat person like me, I could probably start fasting, um, a bit each week.
Right?
Like we all do that, but that's not the, the, the global civilization isn't that efficient.
So we'd be looking at, you know, hundreds of millions of people facing starvation.
That's, that's the type of situation this is.
It's the worst they predicted about the pandemic, but worse than that.
Um, and now you, you, you take that situation and you look at our nations.
Like, you know, how, how do the English people feel about each other?
How do the French, oh my God, dude.
It's like, if the sundown is, is too, too red, uh, you know, someone grabs a band of Frenchmen and goes out and starts, you know, blocking roads and setting fire to cars and shit.
Right?
It's like, it takes very little, but I'm not taking, I'm not trivializing your problems.
I'm saying like, that stuff is fairly normalized in France.
At least in my lifetime, it's happened over and over and over again.
Um, and that's in like relatively good times, like some of the best times in history.
Now, if this continues and everything is collapsing, everyone's losing their jobs and, uh, you know, there's food shortages and fuel shortages.
Um, one of the things that the eschatology, the astrology and the RV agree on, and, and if you guys will remember, right, like the seven people watching now or six people watching now, six great people.
Um, you guys may remember, we did a number of spaces on Astro RV and specifically Astro RV related to this transit, this period of time.
And, uh, we did not do that.
Uh, Morgan and Dan would not run the target, nor would anybody else except there's, um, a decently talented remote viewer named Josh Maitland didn't work with me.
He worked with, uh, Dan waits.
They, they claimed they were under, they had no idea that me and Morgan were doing this.
So, and I'll just take the word for it.
Right.
Like they came up with this idea on their own.
And, um,
Um, they saw this period of time and it was largely categorized by, um, revolutions, revolutions all over the place.
Uh, weak nations being, um, seized by stronger nations, um, UFOs, tons of UFOs, which we would expect if this crisis escalates, to be honest, both from the perspective of like predictions made that UFOs will, will appear, um, during the next global war.
Um, but also just based on the fact that, you know, it's not just the U S that has secret craft, right?
So the weapons that are on the shelf, they're going to get, you know, someone's got them out.
Um, hypothetically, we, we talked a lot about, uh, a large number of remote viewers over the last five years have seen an event where a weapon is used in the ocean that causes tsunamis.
Right.
And that's something that eschatologically speaking in history, prophets saw as well.
And it is something that's mentioned by the way, in the book of revelations, um, the dragon opens his mouth and creates, uh, uh, a flood to destroy the, uh, the church.
I'm not, again, I'm not trying to, um, turn this into, um, some kind of evangelism or whatever, or a Bible discussion.
I'm just saying like, it's there too, right?
Like it's, it, it's, it's everywhere.
But what the remote viewers, modern remote viewers, like they see an, an object and that was seen in the Astro RV work as well.
We know that that's real.
We know that, um, at least Russia has those weapons, right?
They openly have those weapons.
It's not like a secret, uh, weaker countries have to be open about their weapons.
Like the U S is much more likely to have secret weapons than the Russians are or the Chinese, because the U S has a significant conventional military advantage.
So just like in nature, you know, you, um, you know, a, a, a frog, you know, will be bright.
You'll find a bright purple frog to indicate that it's poisonous, right?
Because a frog is relatively defenseless otherwise.
So when you have a, a nation that's, that's somewhat weaker, right?
They have to telegraph their capabilities or have parades where they, you know, they take all the missiles and drive them down the street, you know, to scare people.
That's not a sign of strength.
That's a sign of, of, of needing to scare your opponents away from bothering them, which is a, it's a valid strategy.
Um, so we know they have those weapons, but we, we also know that there are ways that they could potentially use to greater effect.
Um, astrologically, uh, there's nothing I say here in this space that's going to influence global powers or give, put an idea, like put an idea into the heads of,
uh, of a foreign government, right?
These things have been said before in other places.
I just want to make that clear that I'm not, I'm not putting like dangerous stuff out there that hasn't been talked about.
So, you know, there's a volcano in the Canary Islands.
It's like Cumbra de Vejo.
I know my pronunciation is terrible.
I don't mean it disrespectfully.
I just, it's a, it's a personal flaw and weakness.
Uh, I'm, I can barely speak English.
Nevermind pronounce the words from, you know, other languages.
Anyhow, that volcano, um, has built up magma over the years, has built up a, over the years, has built up a giant ledge.
So if you look at the island, you see an island.
And if you go under the water, you see half an island and half a giant ledge with a volcano on top of it.
There's always been a concern, or there's been a concern since like the 70s or 80s, that that ledge could break off.
And if it breaks off, right?
And, and, uh, displaces the, the water in the Atlantic, uh, that would create a tidal wave, um, that would penetrate at least 26 miles inland in the U.S.
And, and also deeply in, in the U.K. and Northern Europe, um, you know, these, this information is from the American media, mainstream American media.
And, um, it's focused mostly on the U.S.
So I can't tell you like, well, what would happen if it hit the U.K.?
I don't know.
But if it hit the U.S., if this, this hypothetical scenario happened, and if it hit the U.S.
And it just goes 26 miles inland.
Well, I mean, there are a hundred million people in the U.S. within 26 miles of the, of the shore on the East Coast, right?
And, uh, virtually our entire economy.
I mean, California is very powerful.
And, you know, so not the whole economy.
But, you know, I mean, it's where, it's where all the money's made.
It's where all the stuff is made.
It's, um, yeah.
Not that that would matter in that case, anyhow, because you'd have all those people.
So I'm not saying that that's what the remote viewing shows.
What I am saying is that they see a, remote viewers who have looked into this, see a significant displacement of water.
Um, just a really catastrophic event.
Um, leading to large population migrations away from the East Coast of the United States to the Midwest.
Intuitive Underground saw that weapon.
Um, Josh Maitland saw it in his Astro RV work.
Um, other remote viewers have seen it.
Future Forecasting Group, um, they aren't the best at hitting targets when they want to, in my opinion.
But they have, uh, a gift for hitting targets that they aren't looking to hit.
So historically, they, they can document the fact that they, while trying to look at other targets, often will all come up with information related to a future event that turns out to be highly predictive.
Uh, 9-11 is one of those cases.
Um, not, not this particular group, but individuals who were part of that group, right?
Um, uh, North Carolina floods, the LA fires, et cetera, et cetera.
Uh, they had this, like, uh, two years ago, 2023, 2000, so two and a half years ago, they were looking at a target.
They all missed the target and they all hit on this series of natural disasters or not.
It's not natural.
This, the series of disasters and they called it the luminosity event.
And they made a series of videos about it.
And once they had started to get information from it, they, they, um, uh, they, they went back and tried to look deeper into it.
And the reason this is apropos to the energy crisis is that the first in a three-stage series of events was, um, was something that I am personally concerned about right now.
Uh, a blackout in the month of April, they saw it happen in New York city.
Um, I don't think it was inclusive to New York city.
I think that what they saw was something larger that affected New York city.
And so the luminosity event would begin with, um, a large blackout on the American East coast, if not larger, um, in April, uh, followed by a political transition in July.
I didn't say anything more about it.
They just say a political transition that could be, that might not even be the U S I mean, that could be like a transition of power.
That could be Prince Charles and Prince William, right?
Um,
where I know they're seen as somewhat symbolic, but their roles aren't as symbolic during large, you know, during a big war, right?
Like they were like very important people during world war two and world war one, et cetera.
Right.
So it would be like a, a highly important event if we're in the middle of a global, um, uh, a global crisis.
And then in September or October, a flooding event on the East coast and they had maps and, um, you know, those maps, what they saw indicated some areas, a few miles of flooding and some areas, 300 miles of flooding.
And I know that sounds crazy, but if you're familiar with the United States, um, the area North of the Gulf of Mexico.
So if you go up through like Alabama, that area is very, very flat.
And if there was, uh, a wave big enough to hypothetically go 26 miles inland in, um, in New England, right?
That wave, it's that flooding itself could flood a large area in the South.
Now, I'm not saying that this is connected to the long emergency necessarily.
I am saying that, um, there, it is possible and it, that's what concerns me.
Um, it concerns me that, uh, fifth column activities are like saboteurs, um, cyber attacks, right?
I think they indicated it was a cyber attack in the original luminosity event, um, sessions, a cyber attack, uh, et cetera.
Um, related to this crisis could, uh, could happen next month.
And if it does, um, it would be a prolonged blackout.
It wouldn't be a blackout of like 12 hours or something.
It would be days or longer, which for people who are unprepared would be a, a major crisis, right?
Like there are things like basic stuff that people don't understand.
Like if you have a long flood, you have to fill your, your tub and your sink with water, take waste pan, like a trash buckets, right?
Put, um, put trash bags in them and fill those with water.
Cause you're going to need the water when the pressure stops for cooking, for washing and for flushing the toilet.
Like little preparation, things like that.
If everyone knew that, then a three day or a seven day blackout wouldn't be the end of the world.
But for somebody who's not prepared and not taking it seriously, right?
Like a three or seven day blackout is a life threatening situation, particularly if you live in a dangerous area.
Okay.
I mean, I can, can you imagine like after all these years of having cameras on us all the time, if the cameras went out for seven days, it's scary to think about.
And that's why it's important to like consider.
Now, the way that ties into the long emergency is, uh, if, if this fuel crisis continues and gets worse, then you are absolutely looking at, at rolling blackouts, absolutely looking at rolling blackouts this year.
Right.
So learning the basics of what to do with the power out, um, like that's important, right?
So like getting asked to pharmaceuticals, getting extra food, learning the basics of what to do when the power goes out.
Like, I know that sounds fantastical.
I know it sounds like a television show.
It's because we've been so lucky in our lives that every major crisis has, has sort of not turned out to be as serious as it could have.
But when you go after the oil, like when you shut off the oil, there is no way, there is nothing that can mitigate that crisis.
Even if they came out with fucking free energy tomorrow and said, this is zero point energy, plug this in.
Okay.
You can't eat it.
You can't make medicine out of it.
Right.
You can't use it to run your, your car and you can use it to run an electric car, but unless you have an electric car, you're screwed.
Like, so even if they released unlimited free energy tomorrow, if the oil doesn't flow, the world is in a serious, serious life-threatening crisis for many people.
Now, right.
And that, that's if, if it doesn't escalate the war, but look at it.
If you were in one of these countries and, you know, suddenly you don't have any fuel, what are you going to do?
You can either roll over or you can, you know, you can say, this is the time we got to do it.
The U S did this to Japan, right?
Like prior to Pearl Harbor, we shut off their oil to the Japanese.
And the Japanese made the decision at that point that they had to attack us.
All right.
Hopefully not, no one will make that decision.
And if they did make that decision, hopefully we would be ready and, and prepared or whatever.
But as individuals, we should be prepared for those things.
Cause like, we're really in this long emergency, this emergency that's going to last for years.
And when, unless this stops tomorrow, if this continues on like this, we're in a long emergency.
It's going to last for years.
And at the end of that life is not going to be the way it was before.
Right.
Like life is not the way on in 2006, life was not the way it was before 9-11.
And in 2005, it was not for most of us, not the way it was prior to the pandemic.
I can say like, certainly in Massachusetts, it was definitely not right.
Like we used to have businesses open till 11 o'clock at night.
Now it's, it's like, we're back to the Puritan times.
You're lucky to find a business open past six o'clock.
I mean, it doesn't seem like a huge thing, but it was a big change to my lifestyle.
Um, people still work at home and a lot of employees with, you know, the, the capabilities to work at home.
Like that's the companies would have rather gotten rid of work from home, but the employees, um, insist on it or they go someplace else.
So that was a permanent change.
Um, there's a big problem with kids who are in school, at least in the U S during the lockdowns, they have, um, a weakness with reading.
And, um, they're, they're struggling academically.
And it's possible that the kids who are in school, at least in certain grades during the pandemic are going to have lifelong, um, educational and career outcomes, um, negative educational career outcomes from that.
So, and that's small compared to what we're dealing with.
Um, it's possible that a lot of the consumption that we're used to.
Um, we'll be gone at least temporarily.
When this is over global supply chains are going to be disrupted when there's no way around that at all.
So like Walmart type stuff, like that's the, I'm sure there'll be some replacements, but if this continues, like that's largely a lot of that is gone.
Right.
You will have to go back to having like smaller Walmarts or smaller versions of that because there won't be as much junk and there won't be so much inexpensive stuff.
But getting through it, I think is the most important thing.
And as you're, you know, stocking up on medicine and you got your food and whatever, and you pay attention to the news, if this meningitis issue grows, right?
If there is, um, another pandemic, another illness comes out of nowhere, like take it seriously.
Um, you know, people debate the seriousness of, of the COVID infection, right?
And everyone has like such strong feelings about it that it's crazy to even talk about it in diogenes.
I know.
Uh, and I'm not, I'm not, I'm not one of those people.
I think it's a, it's a very serious long-term problem.
I think that if you have that infection, all of us who've had that infection have long-term issues that we just might not know about yet.
However, I could be wrong.
Um, but bacterial meningitis, right?
Something like that.
That's, that's, that's a real problem that I don't think anyone can debate.
What's interesting about this is, um, and not something that makes me happy, right?
There are a lot of things remote viewers don't talk about, right?
They, people get into it as like a hobby or a lark or to do something cool.
The people who get involved in it don't have a very responsible personality type, in my opinion.
I'm not disrespecting anyone here or anyone else.
I'm just being honest with you.
I've known and talked to a lot of remote viewers and the idea that there's any type of responsibility on their part implied from being a remote viewer is like a crazy idea.
Um, to everyone I've talked to, right?
They think it's crazy.
It's nuts.
Um, or any type of accountability.
Um, a lot, every remote viewer that I have known on a first name basis has session data that they intentionally will not share or disclose to other people because of how it paints them.
All right.
Or if they think that it might cause a problem or be looked, looked down upon, frowned upon, et cetera.
Uh, that's certainly true with Morgan and Dan.
And I tried, right?
Like I, I, I worked with Morgan for a couple of years.
Um, and I tried to influence them to come forward with all the information they had.
Be completely forthright about it, publish it, write a book, write articles, write more reports.
Um, just get that information out there, right?
Cause they have, as far as I know, the most comprehensive, at least outside the government, most comprehensive set of session data, very systematic investigating reality, investigating a lot of this, these predictive issues, right?
U S and China, um, American elections, things like that.
Okay.
Um, I was unsuccessful.
Um, and the fact that I tried so hard to motivate them to disclose their information, um, led to a, a, a, a rupture, a rift, not just once, but several times.
I believe at this point we're not on speaking terms.
We did speak recently a few times.
Um, but my sense is that following that we're, we're not, we're not on speaking terms again.
Um, and the problem was entirely, like, you can say like, I'm, I'm, I'm, I can be a jackass.
That's true.
Uh, I can be a little intense.
Absolutely true.
Uh, jerk.
Yep.
A hundred percent.
The root issue is that I like very strongly pressure remote viewers to disclose the information they have.
That is relevant to like the welfare of individuals, nations, right?
I mean, it's, to me, it's, it's a moral imperative, right?
It's the reason they were put here on this earth.
And, um, and yeah, they just don't, uh, they don't care for that.
And, uh, Morgan and Dan definitely didn't care for it.
Although we did, you know, I, I like them as people and I, I still support them.
If you're looking for, right.
Uh, if you're looking to hire a mobile, I recommend Morgan and Dan.
Um, if you were looking for instruction on morality and ethics, I would not recommend Morgan and Dan or any other remote viewer that I, that's just, that's just, I'm just being honest.
And if you go back to, and we've talked about this before, um, the first clairvoyant movement that I'm aware of, the Gnostic movement, Gnostic Christianity, um, you know, in their texts, they're very frank about that.
You know, there are three types of people.
One of them are psychics and psychics are capable of great good and great evil, right?
As people, not like some psychics are capable of great good.
And some psychics are capable of great evil.
Like it is inherent in being a psychic that you're capable of great good and great evil, according to these past traditions.
And up until Anthosophy, um, and Rudolf Steiner, theosophy prior to Anthosophy, right?
Like they agreed with that a hundred percent.
So for, for 2000 years, that was a consensus.
Now we can disagree now, um, because modern conception of morality has changed.
Um, and we have to oftentimes disagree about things like that, particularly with someone like myself, um, where I'm very, I'm a, what they call a black and white thinker in that area.
Um, but in this case, one of the things that is often swept under the rug, okay.
About the future series of events, like everyone here should know that remote viewers going back to the point where they went public in the nineties have been predicting something that called the kill shot.
Not everyone agrees.
Okay.
But it was a big part of the organization, the original SciTech organization that brought remote viewing public, um, a solar event leading to, uh, possibly a magnetic pole shift or a physical pole shift, but definitely a solar event leading to, um, a large loss of power.
Um, like a total destruction of the, of the grid, basically, uh, when I was discussing it with them in detail, a little bit of detail, it, it turns out that there's a, there's a couple of things going on at the same time.
And one of them, right.
Is that there are a certain percentage of people who forget, forget everything like they, and a certain percentage of people who behave as if behave as if, um, zombie like behavior.
So the viewers who've seen this session data don't like to talk about it because they don't want to tell people we see zombies in the future.
The only one I know who will talk about it is Sasha from magic and the noise, who also is not on speaking terms with me, uh, because, uh, I did not ask her to run targets for me, but I was suggesting targets.
I thought that she, uh, like for her, her, um, YouTube channel, she interpreted that falsely, but look, you know, we're all inaccurately, uh, interpreted that as me trying to, um, get her to work for me for free.
And that wasn't true.
Um, and sent me like some obnoxious videos of her, like dancing around saying, we don't do this for free.
It was really childish, but she's got whatever she's got going on.
However, I do mention that she did talk about this, right?
So she, she has integrity with reporting her debt or, or at least a certain level of innocence, um, that she's willing to talk about things that other remote viewers are not.
And with her, it was related to the magnetic pole shift, which is again, same thing as the kill shot.
Uh, and at the magnetic pole shift, the result would be a certain percentage of people would forget.
And a certain percentage of people would be out there behaving like zombies.
So, uh, when I, when I was talking to, um, uh, a specific remote viewer about this, he, he did let me know that those two things are not necessarily causally linked there.
They're correlated, but not linked necessarily through causality and that there might be an exposure to a pathogen or a chemical that is responsible for the behavior among the people.
And what's interesting about that is like a, a meningitis pandemic would certainly fit that bill, right?
Like people get meningitis, they go to the hospital, they get treatment in the hospital.
You don't really encounter them.
But if a large number of people got meningitis and weren't able to go to the hospital, like aggressive behavior, right?
Also like running around, you know, screaming and, and, uh, I don't mean to laugh, you know, laugh because it's painful.
Bleeding from the eyes, like shit like that.
That's, those are meningitis symptoms.
And the, one of the diagnostic criteria for meningitis is a purple or blue, um, pinprick type or pinpoint rash on the skin that you take a glass and you press it against the rash.
And if the rash doesn't go away, when you press the glass against it, that is a, a symptom of meningitis.
I'm sure there are other things that have that same symptom, but if you suspect meningitis, that is one of them, right?
And it's sore, physically painful rash.
So that, that pops up in eschatology that, that pops up in the book of revelations where at one point, um, everyone or a lot of people begin to get a, a, a sore.
And, um, immense pain.
They gnaw their tongue with pain from, from the, from the affliction.
It comes up in the Mormon prophecy where the Mormons prophesied that, um, during the apocalypse period, a plague would spring up in the West amongst, um, people, communities where Mormons lived, um, that would be categorized by, uh, people would, the first sign would be the development of the people.
In this sore red or purple spots.
And, uh, that people would be so terrified of it that they would, you know, again, trigger warning, um, you know, mothers would throw their children, physically throw them away from them if they saw the rash.
So, um, it is interesting from that perspective, um, that this is popping up now.
I mean, hopefully it's just 29 people and I ended up just being concerned about something that's not something to be concerned about.
It just, it really ties in with everything.
And, um, if you were talking about when they talk about like, you know, zombie apocalypse, right?
They talk about rabies a lot.
Like, well, if we had a pandemic of rabies, it'd be like a zombie apocalypse.
But if you had a pandemic of meningitis, it would be as well.
And, uh, in the remote viewing data, the kill shot is, and in eschatological data as well, or imagery, the solar event is tied into the war.
The world war, the war in the Middle East, the war in the U S and, and Russia and China, like when people make predictions about that or when they see it, like it's, it's, it's very closely tied together.
Um, the kill shot predictions are that like world war three will be like happening or in the beginning stages and everyone will be out there in the field.
The militaries will be deployed.
And then the sun will, you know, have a micro, um, Nova and that everyone will just turn around and go home because the war's over at that point, basically.
Um, correlating with this behavior among people.
And I don't know, it's just, I guess I'm on this wild digression because I don't know if I can accurately or effectively articulate all the strands of interconnectivity, but they are, they are there.
I've 30 years in this and, um, there's like a very strong connection between those predictions and RV data and the astrology kind of backs it up.
And so again, I hope I'm wrong.
Uh, however, if I, I, I, I, I'm, I'm, I'm beating a dead horse about it because if this fuel crisis continues and we start having blackouts and shit and there's a pandemic, right?
There will be super, super censorship and you're not going to, it's going to be like 2020 times 10 and you're not going to have any access to that.
Information at all.
So, um, no one will be able to talk like I'm talking now or won't have any audience if they're talking like I'm talking now.
And so you won't know how serious to take it.
Right.
But if that happens, it's super, super serious.
What I'm doing right now is I'm, um, I've got this book I've had for years, um, on, uh, psychoneuroimmunology, like actual, um, database exercises you can use, um, to, uh, improve your immune system.
Uh, back when, prior to the development of medicines for AIDS, um, there were a lot of, um, sort of novel treatments.
People were using olive leaf extract or olive leaf tea because olive leaf tea is strongly, um, antiviral and, uh, antifungal.
So, uh, people were drinking a lot of olive tea, not everyone, but it was a thing.
Um, there was also work on the mind body connection to strengthen the immune system, which makes sense because they were immune compromised people.
Let's just assume that a certain percentage of the population is immune compromised now without getting, you know, without beating a dead horse and going back and talking about why.
Um, it seems to me like this is a good time to, I've tried talking about this with people before.
They have no interest.
Like it's even less entertaining than this conversation is, right?
But there are like, like at least seven basic things you can do, like exercises you can do.
I'll give you one example.
Um, there's a psychoneuroimmunological connection between our shame, right?
And like secrets that we hold and our immune system.
This is true.
And they were able to, um, researchers were able to, right?
They would have people come in and journal for five days on the, the thing in their life.
They were most ashamed about that.
They would never tell anyone about it.
We all have something we've done.
We're super, super ashamed about it.
We're never going to tell anyone about it.
Spend 20 minutes each day for five days writing about it.
Don't worry about grammar.
Don't worry about structure.
Just write stream of consciousness.
Don't worry about spaces between words, whatever.
Just write 20 minutes about, about what happened and how you feel.
And, um, over the course of those five days, like it would go from like this giant scrawled, crazy letter to like, um, a very, um, well-written, almost essay.
Right.
But they found that people's immune systems, um, for a period of like, I don't know if they followed them for more than eight weeks, but at least eight weeks later, their immune systems were significantly stronger.
By measuring T cells and, and, and other immune factors.
And, you know, this gets into like the weird, cause we were, we were a lot more new agey back then.
Right.
It was much more acceptable.
So the only way they found to improve that was to do freestyle dance.
I know it sounds weird, but like, I mean, it would sound weird to the guys here.
I may, maybe, maybe not to, well, I don't, I guess in engendering or whatever.
So dancing to express how you feel like a bee, you know, dances to tell the other bees how to get to the flower.
Like dancing to express how you feel for five minutes after you do the writing assignment every day, uh, also improved, um, the immune system at least eight weeks later.
So there are actual like, um, lifestyle changes you can make that aren't involving nutrition.
Right.
It doesn't matter if you're fat like I am.
It doesn't matter.
Like it just, this is just working on the mind body connection that significantly strengthens your immune system.
With viruses, like I, you know, that would be effective, but, um, with bacteria, it's like even more important.
Um, so I'm working on that and trying to figure out some way to, to make it interesting enough that people would want to talk about it.
So this is the long emergency.
It's here to stay.
Um, it would take six to nine months to fix it.
Even if they stopped right now, if they don't stop right now, they're going to be food shortages.
It's going to be gasoline crisis.
It's going to be shut down to society significantly longer and, um, more impactful than the, the lockdowns were.
They already, the UN is already encouraging countries to begin doing the lockdowns now the same way they were already talking about it in February in 2020.
It's definitely true that the U S is probably going to try to resist it and everyone else will go along with it.
But even the U S is going to have to give in, um, if this continues and probably in July, uh, best case scenario, uh, significant limitations of mobility, uh, not being able to get the food that you want when you want it.
And, uh, uh, medicine, you need, you need to get extra medicine because there's going to be medicine shortages.
And God only knows how long those medicine shortages are going to last.
I know I've rambled and I've talked in circles, but as you can see, I want to keep repeating things, both in case someone new showed up, which no one has, but I appreciate all of you.
Like, as you know, I really, really do.
And you guys right here and maybe another six are the reason I'm doing these spaces, honestly, because the people who've like shown support for me and I want to take this opportunity, like one last couple of weeks, I'll be back.
I think in July, cause I want to see, I've made astrological predictions about UFO X and the U S in general.
And I want to touch back on that.
So I'll be here on X until then.
I'll definitely do four spaces, um, until early April.
I might do one around April 12th to talk about the Chris Bledsoe stuff.
And I'll be back in, in July.
I'm definitely not going to do like a ton more than that.
Cause I think that using social media and using devices is disempowering.
Um, and I think it's by design and during a crisis and preparing for a crisis.
I think it's a good, you know, I doom scroll and shit and I need to focus on getting my life together to deal with this as effectively as possible, rather than spending eight hours scrolling on, on X and Instagram every day.
Um, I think that one of the topics that I'll talk about in, right, like I'll do an Armageddon now space, maybe to talk about the military aspect of it in depth.
If anyone has an interest in that, I, I don't have any insider information.
I can't disclose any secrets.
I don't have any, um, this is just observation and a lifetime of research and experience.
I will do, um, Oh, what was I just, oh shit.
Uh, Oh, maybe something about gamifying this.
Right.
So this is how I, uh, how I look at it.
Um, mobility is important.
Like if a person can prep for like 30 years and build a dungeon or I think fringe is building a, um, a bunker claims to has shown pictures of it.
Right.
And she's big into prepping.
If you can, that's great.
Um, if you're in the right place and you can be certain that you'll be safe there and won't have to move.
Like I am not in a living situation where I can, you know, I would have like a lot more than I do, but I'm not in a secure living situation like long-term.
So I can't guarantee that if I have to change my residence, I'll be able to bring any of it.
Right.
So what, what good is having it?
Um, so my goal is six months.
My goal is, cause I'm looking at like 30 months.
If you look at eschatology, right.
You could look at like 40 months or 42 months.
Right.
That's mentioned.
Um, but I think that, uh, you know, 18 months.
So depending on what your, what your goal is, right?
Like food production, maybe you won't be able to get the foods that you want for two years.
Right.
That could be shortages, but maybe in 18 months, there won't be any shortage of grain anymore.
Um, I, I can't say exactly, but, um, I want to get six months ahead and then focus on trying to stay ahead.
Right.
Knowing that I'm going to lose ground over time.
I know that in two years, I won't be six months ahead with food.
I won't be six months ahead with medicine in two years.
Right.
I might be behind.
Like I might not make it two years before I start to slip behind.
But the goal is to just cushion myself for six months.
Um, food for me, cat food, medicine for me, cat medicine, right.
Um, stuff like that.
And, uh, if I think like, if I, if I think about anything that I can get on Amazon that will make it easier to, to drive when there's fuel shortages, um, or cook if the power is out, like secure that stuff now.
And get that ready.
I'm trying to get as much ready for April as possible.
But my goal is July 1st to six months ahead.
Six months ahead of my bills.
Six months ahead on everything.
Now I know that most people can't do that.
I can't do that.
I'm dirt poor, but I scrape and scrimp and, because this is important to me to have the control of my life and try to, and I've been through this, right.
Like I was through this with COVID and stuff.
Like I have experienced preparing for scarcity.
Luckily COVID didn't turn out to be that bad, but I was prepared.
And it was horrible, it was horrible, but you know what I'm saying?
Like we didn't, we didn't start to starve, but we, there were shortages.
And so I was prepared for the shortages.
This time the shortages could be, could be more.
So that's my goal.
And that's what I would, I would tell everyone to gamify it.
Like set a certain number of things to get by a certain period of time, and then make it a game of trying to stay ahead.
You know, know that things are going to be scarce.
You're going to have to go to places you're not used to going to get your medicine.
You're going to have to shop harder to get food, right.
To find the food that you want.
Work with relationships with people in order to get your car, get your car fixed now.
Oh, well, I should have mentioned this right from the beginning.
Cars and electronics, car, car, um, car parts, right.
Already, um, I, I, I knew this, I should have said this right from the beginning.
I knew this and I started getting my car fixed, right.
Um, I know somebody who someone stole his catalytic converter a few nights ago, which is already a sign of, of things getting bad.
Like, you know, in the U S you know, when things are, when the crisis is approaching because people start stealing catalytic converters.
Um, in, in, in, it was his, uh, Volkswagen and it's going to cost him like $2,500 to repair it.
It's going to cost him like $3,000 to repair it, but he had to get a re, uh, rebuilt catalytic converter because right now in North America, for his vehicle, there are no catalytic converters available.
The companies that make, uh, in North America, I don't know anybody knows in this case, the companies who make the rebuilt automotive parts are really struggling.
Um, and some of them are going out of business and there was some thought that this is somewhat by design, um, because companies want to like companies who, um, both the companies and the bureaucrats want us to have newer cars.
Right.
And this, I know it's going to sound crazy, but in 2027, all U S cars are going to watch the driver.
I know that sounds crazy, but it's actually true.
It's not like if you said that in the 1990s, they would lock you up.
It's actually true.
Like all new cars in 2027 are going to surveil the driver to make sure that you're paying attention to the road.
So you can have a camera on you.
That's going to watch where you look and shit.
So in order for that to be successful, they got to get all the old cars out.
Right.
So there's some thought there's like a design behind it, but it is true that the companies that, that make the rebuilt engines are starting to go out of business.
In the short term, right?
Like there are going to be shortage of automobile, automotive parts this year and next year.
You're not going to be able to get parts.
So if you know there's something wrong with your car that has to get fixed, get it fixed now.
Cause you, you won't be able to get the part.
It will not exist.
Electronics.
If there's an electronics item you want to buy now, right?
It may not be available in England.
It may not be available in North America for a while.
It may like, we don't have remote viewing data on every item, that type of thing.
But we know there are going to be like real shortages.
Like it's, you can't get it.
So, you know, think about that.
And again, I understand not having any money.
I don't have any money.
Right.
I'm just saying, you know, think of it as a game.
What can you do?
What can you do in the short term to just a little bit better?
Get a little bit ahead.
All right.
That's it.
I know.
Thank you for listening to me ramble for two hours and 10 minutes.
I always appreciate it.
I think everyone here are people who actually listen and not people who put it on in the background and yell at me.
So hopefully other people will listen to this.
I usually get like another 10 or 20 people.
And if just one or two people makes a decision that helps them over the next year or two, then it was well worth making this space.
If no one does, it's still okay.
Like I have to assuage my conscience because I know this is going to happen.
I know this is happening.
I knew the pandemic was coming, right?
Like I couldn't do anything to help people at that time.
I couldn't.
I had no ability to do that.
But I do have the opportunity to do that this time.
And so I have to at least try.
And if it has no, if no one cares or it's not entertaining or, you know, that's fine.
That's fine.
As long as I try to do it.
So I'm going to do another three spaces.
And if you guys want to come by, that's great.
If it's just going to be like redundant or, and you don't want to come by, that's, that's fine too.
I understand.
And if I end up like not having anyone show up, then that's fine too.
I'll just wait half an hour and cancel the space.
But I need to just,
take this opportunity, put it out there so I can look back and say, look, those, the people who are, you know, nice, right?
The people who are nice that I got along with online, like on X, like I, I told them what I, what I knew and tried to give them a chance to have an advantage.
So that's, that's, that's, that's all I've got for tonight.
Uh, if anyone has anything, any comments, questions, concerns, uh, Diogenes, if you have any stories about France, uh, I don't know if they're setting tires on fire yet or, um, blocking the roads with the, the, the wooden sawhorses.
Those are the only images I ever see.
I don't know.
I know it's small compared to how it's portrayed.
Um, but those are the images we always see.
So that's what sticks with me during crisis periods.
Oh yeah.
Um, France is one of the countries.
Uh, UK is identified by some viewers and is identified.
I haven't looked at France and the UK's astrological charts.
I can, but I wasn't planning on making predictions about, um, I wasn't planning on doing, I should do, uh, a space of astrological predictions for countries.
In which case I'll have that information ready.
Uh, uh, the UK is one of the countries, particularly if the war continues to escalate, that is likely to experience domestic disturbances.
But France is definitely right.
And that's not just me joking around about the, you know, that's, that's out of the RV data.
That's out of the eschatological data.
I haven't looked at the astrology yet, but you know, it, it is, France is one of the countries where you might have a different government soon.
You might go through a couple, I mean, knowing France, you might go through a couple of governments in this period of time.
Right.
But like, you definitely might have a different government soon in France.
So when we know about the U S and concerns there, but definitely France and Italy, um, are two that are all different.
They're always, they always come up.
So.
All right, guys, anyone comments, questions, concerns?
I know it's.
I'm the most doom of any doomer.
You know, after, when I did the, uh, doom room with doomer and fringe, they were like, you know, you're the most doom of anyone.
And to be honest, I had like, I had limited how, um, how much doom I, I spoke about, but they didn't have me.
What about Turkey?
Um, I Turkey is a, oh, uh, Kabbalah is.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Um, Thomas, I, I will, uh, I will look at that.
It's not my, my thing.
Um, I'll tell you, uh, as a prognosticator, right?
Well, first of all, I think that all people have a tendency towards evil.
And so I don't scapegoat one group of people because I think that left to our own devices, people have a tendency to evil.
I think that that's where we are.
Uh, I don't know if you're still listening, but, uh, if you are, or if you listen to this later, um, so I don't, I don't intentionally get involved.
I intentionally don't get involved in scapegoating any group of people.
I assume that there are a multitude of, uh, cultures and religious beliefs and organizations that have an aspect to them that involves conspiracy because I've encountered it every time and everywhere I go in my life.
Right.
Like, even if you have a job, um, as a waiter, right.
Uh, or three or four waiters there on the floor and whoever walks out of the restaurant, the three that are left, I'm going to talk shit about them for the next hour and a half.
It seems to be human nature.
Um, I don't discount the fact that there are people involved, um, who have bad intentions, but I don't focus on any, on any one group because I wouldn't be able to be an effective true or false true or not.
I wouldn't be able to be an effective prognosticator if I was political or if I, um, was overly concerned with the behavior of one group of people or another group of people, it would, it would affect my, um, I would, I would develop different types of cognitive bias.
That would affect my ability to relate the information accurately.
So, um, that's just not, you're not going to hear me, uh, single out one country or one group other than in specific examples and say that country or that group is the country or group causing all the problems in the world.
Because it's, you know, we're all causing all the problems in the world, man, right?
One of the reasons that these X bases aren't very effective is that people don't want to hear it.
Well, people don't want to hear it.
Like at a certain point, they're making a choice to be part of the problem.
Right?
So honestly, um, there is no individual group of individuals, government organization, powerful or sophisticated or intelligent enough to cause the problems in the world for everyone else.
If everyone else wasn't complicit in those problems, that's just the truth.
Uh, there are too many people and we're, we're pretty smart.
So, um, as far as a sin in, I think you're gone.
I'm sorry that I didn't see your, your message, but if you listen to this later, Turkey, um, eschatologically speaking, uh, I don't have any wrongdoing data on Turkey.
I don't that I know.
I don't have any astrological data on Turkey.
I know S S S I'm sorry.
I'm losing my ability to speak.
Um, um, clairvoyants in the past have, uh, have discussed Turkey.
Um, it's possible.
I I've heard both sides of it that Turkey will, will end up siding against NATO in the war.
Um, or, uh, Turkey will, will be affected poorly because it sides with NATO in the war.
Um, I do know that, uh, that other middle Eastern nation, right.
Um, they did say, uh, once Iran is gone, Turkey is our, is the main threat to our existence.
That was concerning when I heard that on the news, um, because Turkey is a NATO partner.
So I said, I don't know how that's going to work because Turkey is a NATO partner.
Um, so yeah, Turkey is going to be deeply involved in, in this war in, in the not too distant future, in my opinion, but I don't have any specific RV data or astrology to back up at this time, but I will look into it.
And I'll have that information, not in the next space, but in one of the next spaces, I will make sure to have information about, um, Turkey that I can find.
I don't know if it's, it's part of a Muslim prophecy or not.
I mean, I would imagine, um, but Turkey can tend to be very secular, right?
I mean, I know, uh, they're not as much now, but you, you, you've been very secular.
So it would be hard for me to imagine you fitting in well with, uh, the whole moddy thing, but I'll look into it.
Uh, anyone else, anyone got anything?
Because otherwise I'm going to wrap it up and I, because I'm so used to this stuff, like I'll feel fine.
Once I, I'm going to go hang out with the cats and watching TV or something.
I'm sorry if, if anything I said is depressing.
It is depressing to people when they first start hearing it.
Um, just like our other stuff, right?
Like when you start talking about like, how does the simulation work?
People get very depressed when they hear that too.
Um, I don't, I don't, I always try to get people trigger warning.
Uh, yeah.
So the next one is going to be, uh, Armageddon now, um, talking about, uh, similarities between the war and the Middle East and various, um, religious traditions and independent, um, independent profits, exact predictions.
About what will happen during that, uh, war.
I hope you all have a great night and I hope you all will at least stock up on medicine.
All right.
And, uh, remember that if the power goes out for more than a day or two, right, the lines are going to lose pressure.
So make sure to fill up your, your tub, your sink, the buckets, et cetera.
Cause you can go, you know, most of us can go 30 days without food.
I could go significantly longer.
I'm sure.
Uh, but you can't go 30 days without water.
All right, guys.
Have a good night.
So it would be 15 seconds, right?
Before, um, it cuts out.
Um.
Thank you.